The crocodile sat up and said, "I don't feel any more pain."
"It's all gone!"
Then he saw the mouse walking down his tummy,...
...carrying an enormous crocodile tooth on his shoulder.
"Your bad tooth was giving you the toothache!" answered the mouse,...
...turning around to face the now smiling crocodile.
"Do you want it back?"
"Oh no, no, no, no get rid of it,...
...and when you've done that, come back, I'll have a present for you."
The mouse went and buried the bad tooth under a tree,...
...and when he returned, the crocodile had a nice juicy nut waiting for him.
As the crocodile watched the mouse eating the nut, he said to him,...
"You were very clever, getting rid of my toothache, and kind too.
I am so grateful.
But what shall I do if my toothache comes back?"
"Don't worry, I'll help you take care of your teeth," answered the mouse nibbling.
Soon the crocodile and the mouse were the best of friends.
And one day the crocodile sent all the animals an invitation.
"Please come to drink and bathe in the river!
I won't hurt you!
"The river belongs to us all!" he said.
The creatures weren't afraid to drink and bathe in the river anymore.
Although the crocodile was sometimes snappy, they grew to love him.
And soon the river was full of fish and tadpoles and crabs and crayfish.